[Musique]
imaginez arrivée au bureau le matin et
vous retrouver devant un accès internet
comme celui ci je veux rentrer une tâche
phrase attendent encore celle permise
par l'usiné de carton que dirige marie
hélène côté pourtant située à lavaltrie
à seulement 40 minutes de montréal
si quelqu'un connait l'urgence d'agir
l'urgence de fournir l'internet haute
vitesse dans la région c'est bien david
morin il est grand responsable des
technologies dans la mrc d'autray aussi
critiqué des entreprises qui sont
présentement dans le quartier industriel
qui nous est si vous avez prêté en est
on songe également à quitter donc levé
l'eau du bain il faut faire quelque
chose
c'est le lyonnais à haute vitesse en
ottawa et québec annonce des millions
pour déployer la haute vitesse en région
que 100 % des citoyens aient accès à
internet haute vitesse
monsieur morin s'est empressé de
soumettre la candidature de sa mrc
on a soumis au programme canadien au
programme québécois 255 documents
certains c'est à dire fichier excel de
10 12 15 ans ont d'elle donc ça a été un
travail de plusieurs mots justes mots
tels dossiers
en décembre 2010 est l'inversé de
monsieur m'aurait reçoit alors 4,7
millions de dollars mais pour lui la
course à obstacles ne fait que commencer
c'est là qu'on était quand même un peu
déçu parce que disons qu'on croyait
admissibles au complet y en a plusieurs
qui ont disparu même si le projet de
fibre de la mrc d'autres y passe tout
près de 5,8 berre et saint barthelémy
impossible d'utiliser la subvention pour
brancher les deux villages pourquoi
parce que selon les critères du
gouvernement les deux villages ont déjà
accès de la haute vitesse nous ce
territoire s'est fait retirer des ondes
des endroits les gens faisaient 5 points
2 mégabits
considérant que c'était de la haute
vitesse sa méga bits et un peu
d'internet
la page ben pareil ça prend du temps à
apparaître sur vous pourrez profiter
d'un flic c'est impossible aujourd'hui
de crtc estime qu'il faut environ 50
mégabits seconde dix fois plus pour que
ça soit considérée comme de la vraie
haute vitesse le problème c'est que les
programmes de québec et ottawa pour
brancher les municipalités rurales ont
été lancés en décembre 2016 et en
baissant de 2016 la norme crtc pour la
route vitesse était de seulement 5
mégabits seconde
selon david morin un autre obstacle
majeur se dresse dans son projet de
brancher la mrc afin qu'une entreprise
une mrc un obnl construit un projet
construit un réseau fibre optique
il faut obtenir l'autorisation donc les
permis dans la mrc de monsieur morin
c'est abel que revient le pouvoir
d'octroyer le permis ça veut dire
qu'avant de laisser la mrc est installé
sa fibre optique
il faut que bell inspectent de chaque
poteau et chaque pièce d'équipement ce
moment la belle va pas si tu vas le voir
mon le poteau numéro un ce qu'il est
conforme à ce que les âges aussi que les
pourris parce que l'eurobike roche à ce
qu'il faut refaire le poteau et chaque
poteau vont faire l'objet d'un permis
si un poteau et croches et une pièce
d'équipement est mal en point
et bien la mrc doit piger dans sa
subvention pour financer la remise à
neuf des infrastructures dans ce cas ci
on l'évalué environ facilement à plus de
500 mille dollars de l'envelope de notre
projet c'est même pas mettre notre câble
s'est on met à jour leurs
infrastructures un demi million ces 12 %
de la subvention et le travail de mise à
niveau des poteaux va prendre du temps
dans ce cas si l'on parle juste un
exemple construire 5 km à lavaltrie
c'est trop en mode attente ici on parle
de 200 km donc on s'attend facilement
une bonne année d'attentes pour avoir
l'autorisation complète pour construire
pour l'entreprise de marier les deux
potes il est urgent d'avoir accès à de
la vraie haute vitesse la compagnie
vient d'investir 50 mille dollars dans
une si un format tease et qui doit être
connecté au réseau
d'abord une machine qui est arrêté
pendant plusieurs heures alors qu'elle
était présentée à 5 heures du matin y a
pas de production tant qu'on n'est pas
capable de que la connexion internet
dans le fond fournissent les réponses la
vitesse n'était cependant les réponses
on le sent que ça convient à craindre
david morin estime que si tout va bien
la haute vitesse sera disponible dans la
mrc d'autray en 2021 2021 ses 5,1 entre
les annonces des gouvernements et
l'arrivée de la haute vitesse dans la
région